कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में के
वृक्ष एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
पिछले वाले हैं सेकंड पाठक if you like
this one पर उस वहां पर जाने से पहले आए
हो कि आप सब लोगों ने पहला पाठ देखा होगा
और उस पर से कम से कम 40 50 सेंटेंसेस बंद
देखे होंगे बनाकर विकेट्स very-very
इंपोर्टेंट क्या अभी यह आपको की डिफिसिट
रोटर बाल या इस खबर उड़न बाल या फिर
ड्यूटी आना चाहिए इसलिए अगर आपने
परफेक्टली किया है अगर अपने 50 सेंटेंस
बनाया है तो आगे का बहुत ही इजी है देखो
अगर आपने अभी तक फोन नहीं किए हैं और अगर
आप यह देख रहे हो तो फिर आपको थोड़ा सा
बहुत प्रॉब्लम होगा फिर तीन टेबल से
कंफ्यूज हो जाओगे और उसका उल्टा यह भी है
कि अगर आपका व हो गया तो आपको ऑलमोस्ट 20%
हो गया है बाकी के जो आज आप सीखने वाले
हैं हम कभी-कभी यूज करने वाले हैं उसका
ट्रीटमेंट में देने वाला हूं तो बैक साइड
प्लीज मेक श्योर कि अगर आप यहां पर शुरू
कर रहे हो तो उससे पहले आपका
झाला सब क्लियर हो ओके तो चलिए शुरू करते
हैं सबसे पहले थोड़ी सी डिवीजन से शुरू
करते हैं ओके तो सबसे पहले क्या है कि
आदित्य ऐडेड टो डिलीवर जून मतलब क्या की
वजह से नॉन चेंज होगा वैसे अट्रैक्टिव
चेंज हो का अच्छा अच्छी जैसे हम हिंदी में
करते थे वैसे हम यहां पर भी करेंगे तो वह
को पता है अनफॉर्चूनेटली क्या है एक नहीं
तीन टेबल होंगे कौन-कौन से टाइप होंगे
आपने देखा था पहला डिफरेंट आर्टिकल के साथ
दूध के साथ इंग्लिश में होता है दूसरा
इंडेफिनिटी आर्टिकल के साथ जिसे इंग्लिश
में और कैसा होता है और तीसरा विदाउट
आर्टिकल और हमें जो तीसरा था व हमने लास्ट
परफेक्टली सीखा था की उसको पूरा टाइम में
हमने सीखा था कि वक्त बीत ब्रेड ऑयल या
फिर आए हैं ब्रेड फोन कैसे करना है तो जब
स्क्रीन की सेटिंग्स दिखाएं
टेबल
मेरा टैब इन थे जेनिटिव ने बोला था कि हम
देखने वाले हैं कि नहीं इतना तो जैसा हमने
बोला कि नॉर्मल आपके पेट दर्द स्टेप पत्ता
पर हमने इस साल कैसे किया मुझे सिर्फ मेल
सॉल्व करके दिखाता हूं जिस रेड बॉल रैंक
वंडरलैंड किया नॉमिनेटिव में इस डस्ट रोटर
बाल आई है वह डौ ब्रेड को अंडरलाइन किया
है पूजा ट्यूबवैल इस खबर होटल बाल और आप
विड्रॉल रेड कॉर्नर लाइन किया डाट ईमेल इस
किलोमीटर और टेमबल एकदम सिंपल है बट अगर
यह क्लियर है तो नेक्स्ट एकदम सिंपल है तो
सेकंड पार्ट देखते हैं हम इन डिफरेंट
पार्टी के साथ मतलब इंग्लिश में और के साथ
यहां आई लाइनर के साथ तो एग्जांपल लेते
हैं तो हम कहते हो सकता कि वहीं इस रेड
बॉल या फिर आए हैं अगर मेडिकल तो इसका
कैसे करना है देखते हैं तो उसके लिए
सूटेबल है वह देखिए तो अगर आप यह टेबल
देखोगे ना तो जैसे आपका पहला टेबल
नैनो पार्टिकल वाला वैसे ही अ देखोगे ऐड
सेम है फिर क्या हुआ लास्ट का कॉलम जो है
वह यौवन गया है और लास्ट के दो रोज दारु
सारे पीएम बन गए अध्यक्ष हाय रे मेंबर आप
हर आप अपना पोर्टेबल भी रट्टा मार की याद
रख सकते हैं मैं आई लाइक टू लिप लॉक जो
पहला और टेबलेट उससे क्या कनेक्शन है डोंट
यू और किंतु दोनों ही एंड बन गए हैं और
पूरा-पूरा पीएम बन गया दर्द डिफरेंस
अभियुक्त देखिए कैसे करना है मैं आपको
बताता हूं दीक्षित और रेड बॉल तो उन
जख़्मो किस-किस को अंडरलाइन होगा वह भी
चलेगा रेड भी चलेगा रेट मेरा अच्छा बच्चा
मेरी अच्छी बच्ची दोनों चलते हैं मेरा भी
चलता है अच्छा विकल्प है वैसे ही दिस इस
रेड बॉल क्वार्टर लाइन होगा और कि क्या
देखोगे अपना नार्मल पुराना कैसे सोलर टेबल
नॉमिनेटिव का मेल आई एम रेड को भी आप अंडर
लाइन करोगे रेड के लिए क्या होगा गेंद
नॉमिनेटिव मेल क्या है देखो
को शेयर की है रोटेटर इसीलिए उदास इस्ट
आइन रोटेटर बाल सिंपल है जैसे Amazing
अकोर्डिंग करते हैं आए है वह रेड बॉल कि
डॉक्टर लाइन अपने पुराने टेबल से आपको
जातियों में लाइन था और यहां पर आपको जरूर
मिल रोड 0 इस हां वह इन थे रोट बल ऐसे ही
अगर आपको डाउनलोड करना है आई प्ले विद रेड
बॉल और नीचे अंडरलाइन होगा ट्यूबवैल किया
था हिना नेम पर यहां पर थोड़ा सा चेंज यह
देखिए यहां पर अगर आप देखोगे तो ट्यून
मेरी क्या है रोड के टेबल में एंड लगेगा
इसीलिए उस प्लम्मेट आईने रुटीन थल थोड़ा
सा चेंज राइड अगर आप देखोगे
तो बेसिकली क्या है कि आपने पहले तो कटिंग
के लिए अपना चीज और ऐड कीजिए मेरे सिंपल
अब हम साढ़े 12 के12 नहीं करके देखेंगे
क्योंकि वह बहुत बड़ा हो जाएगा और अब मैं
क्या करने वाला हूं कि इसके नीचे इस
वीडियो के नीचे कमेंट सेक्शन में 10
क्वेश्चन आंसर्स लिखने वाला हूं आप चेक
करते हो आप कर सकते हो तो यह पूरा हो
जाएगा तो चेक कर सकते हो और कोई मुझसे
पूछे तो यहां तक क्लियर है कि और तो और
मां घृत एक-एक करके दिखाता हूं कि हमने
कैसे किया था उस टाइम को रिप्लेस किया और
जो भी बनता है और को रिप्लेस किया तो
इसमें भी कैसे होगा Play Store के लिए
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट होगा और होगा और बाद
टाइनी फिर माय नेम होगा इश्क लिमिट -
प्रोटेबल एकदम सिंपल बट अट लीस्ट यू अरे
ग्रेट वॉल इश्क लिमिट दाहिने मोटे बॉल
अगले थिस ग्रेट वॉल स्पीड लिमिट ज्वाइन
प्रोटीन बॉल एकदम इलेक्ट्रॉनिक इधर ही कि
अगर आपको और है तो मां यूअर हिस अगर आपको
पूरक फ्री मिल गए प्लेयर अगर यहां तक हो
गया है तो आपका ऑलमोस्ट हो गया कि जो
तड़के सेवन बहुत कम यूज करने वाले हैं पर
फिर भी हम वह सीख लेते हैं तो अभी तक आपने
क्या देखा आए हैं और रेड बॉल आएगा और रेड
बॉल अब हम देखते हैं आइए हम दो रेड बुल के
लिए क्या होता है कि संचार होता है तो
उसके लिए टेबल देखो यह थोड़ा सा अलग है
अगले दिन जैसे मैंने बोला आप अपनी तरीके
से याद रख सकते हो मुझे फ्लोर में रखना
याद इजी है इसलिए मैंने क्या देखा सेकंड
टेबल टेनिस टेबल में क्या डिफरेंस है को
लास्ट के दो कॉल गर्ल जो जो रोज है वह यह
नहीं है लास्ट कॉलम यह नहीं है सिर्फ बाकी
सब
कि हो गया है अपनी सेटिंग्स मेरी छोड़कर
सिर्फ योग्य नहीं है इस टेबल में समझे मैं
नॉमिनेटिव सारा की पुष्टि में भी कि सिर्फ
एक कप सूजी टू मिलीयन है और बाकी सब तो यह
था कि लास्ट टेबल में अज्ञेय जैसे याद
रखना है वह आप अपने इसके डिसाइड कर सकते
हो तो इसको भी हम चला कर देखते हैं एक
मेरी के लिए आप जिस बैड गर्लफ्रेंड को
रिसीव द ग्रेट वॉल इसके द काउंटर लाइन
होगा का यह माप मिनट ईमेल क्या होगा देर
और बॉईल के लिए भी यहां पर देखो नॉमिनेटिव
मेल क्या है कि है डाइजेस्ट डेट्रोइट बाल
अभी ऐसा क्यों है इसका कोई विजन नहीं हर
लैंग्वेज कप नहीं होते हैं यहां पर मैंने
से ही क्यों रखा पर अखरोट पता टेबल है तो
ऐड सिस्ट ड्रॉप डब्बा अभी आए हैं उधर रेड
बॉल फिर से द काउंटर लाइनर पॉजिटिव मेल
अपने दो कि नॉर्मल टेबल में डेन और यहां
टॉप टेन एलियन है थोड़ा इजी है टोटल नहीं
होगा इस हां बेन रोड्स इन थे ओवल और डैड
आई प्ले विद रेड बॉल फिर से दक्षिणी
Channel and dont ईमेल डैम यहां पर भी द
के नीचे वंडरलैंड ट्यूबवैल की एन इस
किल्लर मित डेम ब्रोट इन थे पिक्चर अट तो
इसको प्रैक्टिस लगेगी इफिजी इन थिअरी पर
इसको प्रैक्टिस लगी तो इन अश्लील अगर आप
देखोगे तो आपको तीन टेबल देख रहे होंगे
इसलिए कि अगर कुछ नहीं है तो एक टेबल और
है तो एक टेबल है तो एक टेबल रफी डेट में
प्रिटी मैथमेटिकल रहेगी अभी क्वेश्चन यह
है कि वह यह अपने फास्ट होगा कैसे तो इसके
लिए मैं आपके ट्रिक देता हूं तो उनको
शांति से समझ लो अगर आपको ग्रेट कंफर्म
समझ में आई है कि वह यह तीन टेबल है और
कब-कब यूज करने हैं तो नेक्स्ट इसमें समझ
लो कि को किसी भी लैंग्वेज के चार पार्ट
होते हैं डेट में
चीन और एग्जाम में ले संयोजन Reliance
प्रश्न मतलब सुनना पढ़ना बोलना और लिखना
तो उसमें सुनने और पढ़ने में टेंशन है ही
नहीं कि वो प्रोटेबल देखा यार उठ अनमोल
दिखा को तो रेड बुल बताइए तो यह नॉट रियली
वारिड अबाउट थे फिर है क्या गया सिपरेशन
ओर श्राद्ध श्राद्ध पक्ष में फिर भी आपके
पास टाइम रहता है जब भी ऐसी कोई सिचुएशन
है वो टाइम कि वह के दौरान बुलाया है तो
इसलिए तो मैं यह टेबल सोचूंगा आपके पास
सोचने का टाइम है यू कैन थिंक और और फिर
आप यह आंसर लिख सकते हो और प्लैन है
स्पेशल का इधर-उधर बोलना तो है और यह कैंप
तीन टेबल देखोगे और आंसर देखोगे तो इसके
मेरे पास एक तरीके दोस्तों इधर थोड़ा आई
यूज फ्रॉम माय भी वन लेवल कि बिंदास जॉब
विदाउट आर्टिकल वाला टेबल है ना वो टाइट
हर बार यूज कर उसके दो फायदे हैं एक तो व
के दर्द की वह जैसा ही है तो अगर आपको
स्पिलैटोमेटें बाल है तो इस किलोमीटर
टेंपल अपने आप आएगा इस वेरी वेरी
में आ इंट्यूटिव और दूसरा कि बहुत सारी
प्लेसिस पर अगर आप वैसे भी करोगे तो अ मठ
की पर सेंट आफ थे टाइम हुआ और इन दोनों के
पीस में भी ओके बाय गए हैं और उतना
विरुद्ध अपने को ए कोर्स इन एक्यूरेसी
चलेगा आपका प्रिवेंट होना आपको डाइरैक्ट
ढूंढते हैं ना ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट है आप
ऐसे तीन टेबल का करने से तो ट्रिक क्या
मैंने बताई कि वह शुरूआत में पहले बगैर
सोचे जो भी अभिदान प्रैक्टिकल वाला टेबल
है वह ज्यादा ज्यादा यूज डाइरैक्टली करने
की कोशिश करो है जैसे-जैसे टाइम जाता
जाएगा जिससे आप ज्यादा ज्यादा करते जाओगे
वैसे अपने आप को याद आ जायेगा रे स्पीड
लिमिट मायने प्रोटीन होता है अभी यह मैंने
5 6 7 किया था इसलिए मेरे को याद मेरा
मुझे आता है यह और वह मैं आपको भी आएगा
डोंट वरी अबाउट इट विल कम विद टाइम शुरुआत
में हुई गोल एटलीस्ट प्रदेश कंसेप्ट कि
भाई स्पीकिंग में मिट्टी 90% एक्यूरेसी हम
जा सकते हैं एनीवे शर्मा एवं
अपने लिखने में हुई हैव इनफ टाइम ले
जानवरों में फर्क पड़ता ही नहीं तो और
उससे ज्यादा अपने को फर्क नहीं पड़ता है
ओके तो बिफोर कनक्लूडिंग नेक्स्ट 2 मिनट
में जो बोलने वाला हूं वह आपने सुनते ही
भूल गए तो चलेगा पर जस्ट टू अवर
कंजर्वेटिव में एडजेक्टिव अंदर हम देखेंगे
एक तो अनगिनत कितना यूज करेंगे इसमें
अट्रैक्टिव ने कितने लगेंगे और इसे
डिफरेंट पार्ट परचेज टो कंपलीट कंसेप्ट
मैं आपको एक सेंटेंस देता हूं आई लाइक माय
ओल्ड कार्स कलर से कौन बोलता है पर ले आए
लाइफ मैं ओल्ड कार्स कलर तो क्या होगा
देखो इस मास्क पावर क्या होता है कुछ फॉर
मतलब कलर्स आफ फीमेल तो यहां पर वह क्या
है अपुन जगदीश पर इस मार दी पर अब उसके
बाद क्या लगेगा माय कार माइक्रा कार क्या
है नॉमिनेट सरकार क्या है न्यूट्रल पर इस
केस में वह एडिटिव इसलिए - और टोल ओं
कि अगर आप देखोगे इनेक्टिव में क्या होता
है एडिक्टिव एंड सोम देखो न्यूट्रल का ही
काम इसीलिए इस माधुरी 5वां - अलोन इन ऑटोस
डोंट गिव एग्जांपल अगर आपको करना यह तो
कैसे करना है मैंने आपको बता दिया है
नॉर्मल ही नहीं तो फिर से हम अपने बेसिक्स
पर आते हैं कि हमने क्या करते हैं सब कुछ
तो वह शुरूआत में मतलब क्या है जो आपने
देखा था वैसे ही अच्छा बच्चा बच्ची वैसे
तो इसी वजह से हमने मेरा बच्चा मेरी बच्ची
में हमने देर लग सकता है - लग सकता है यह
को था वैसे अच्छा अच्छी हो गया था नेक्स्ट
लेवल प्रॉब्लम्स कि
अजय टेबल नहीं तीन टेबल थे कि और गुड़ के
लिए अगर दौड़ के अलग अ के लिए अलग और
सिर्फ गुड़ के लिए तो हमने शांति से एक के
बाद एक के बाद एक टेबल देखिए मेरा देखने
का एक फ्लोर है कि पहले में विदाउट पार्टी
करवा देता हूं और उसके बाद और के पास जाता
उसके बाद जब के पास अगर आपको ऐसे ही याद
रखना है तो आप अलग-अलग याद रख सकते हो
ट्रिक मैंने क्या बोली कि वह जैसे जो भी
हूं अगर आए हैं और कार है तो और कुंटल एंड
करो आए हैं अब दौरान कार है तो दौड़ डोंट
लाइक करो आया और करें तो डोंट लाइक करो और
रिस्पेक्टिव टेबल देखो इस वेरी वेरी सिंपल
याद किया रखना है लेजर यॉर्क में तो उनको
फर्क पड़ता ही नहीं इस रिबन में हमारे पास
इनफ टाइम है कि हमने इक्विटेबल कहीं में
लिखिए लेकर भी वह कर सकते हैं अगर आपको
करना है ऑपरेशन में टेंशन नहीं लेना और
डायरेक्ट जो भी विदाउट आर्टिकल वाला है कि
वह इंट्यूटिव है इस बटन बाल स्पीड लिमिट
कि रोटी बॉल डायरेक्टरी बोल देना थोड़ा सा
जो इलेक्ट्रीशियन उतना हम इस परीक्षण में
ले सकते हैं परिषद में आपकी बोलने की जो
फोटो है वह ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट है एकदम
हंड्रेड परसेंट डेकोरेटिव लेने के लिए तो
गाइस इस डस्ट एंड मेक नो मिस्टेक यह
कंसेप्ट है यह कंसेप्ट ब्रदर्स एंड कि
मैंने छह-सात साल सीखा है फिर भी एडिटर्स
एंड ऑलवेज कम राइट फॉर न्यू ऑल सोंग तो
उसको टाइम लगेगा वह सिर्फ प्रैक्टिस से ही
आएगी और वह कैसे है कि थोड़ा सा आपके जैसे
दादी-नानी जैसे हमारी थी कि वह उन्होंने
तो कभी हिंदी ऐसे मुख से नहीं सीखी थी पर
वह किरदार का किरदार की किरदार को काफी को
एकदम लिखता तो सिमिलर टो करेक्टली इससे
कितना विदाउट लर्निंग हिंदी ग्रामर वैसे
ही जैसे जिससे आप ज्यादा यूज करते जाओगे
वह इजी बनता जाएगा पर जब तक आपको नहीं आता
है स्टेप बाय स्टेप स्टेप बाय स्टेप करोगे
तो गलती नहीं होगी यह स्लो हो गया नाम पर
गलती नहीं हूं जैसे-जैसे
कि आगे जाओगे वेस्ट अपना दिमाग आपको लग
रहा था जाएगा और फिर डाइरैक्टली भूल पाओगे
मुझे आशा है कि आपको यह कैंसर समझ में आए
होगी हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में
धन्यवाद